on this border every bag is checked
every person questioned get past here
and you're free to roam across europe
this area is known for smuggling gun
running and people trafficking it's
policed by both the albanian guards
and the eu specialist border force
frontex
vehicles are scanned and searched and
it's dangerous criminals are determined
to get across this frontier
down the road we join a border patrol
it's mountainous tough terrain and
they've spotted a group of tents that
could be a hideout for smugglers
because uh one-tenth for example is okay
but five or six
could be a little bit suspicious so we
are checking this now
and
after that we send a message
to the headquarter if it's okay
there are signs of life here
but whoever was using this camp has gone
albania does have a reputation for
corruption and a violent mafia and the
tentacles spread far much of london's
illegal drugs market is controlled by
albanian gangs that's something the
british government is watching as more
and more albanians are trafficked to the
uk
this place knows about migration in fact
the vast majority of albanians live
outside their country but over the past
few years what we've seen is a huge rise
in the number of people leaving here
heading to calais
and then trying to get into britain on
board dinghies in fact
albanians now make a greater proportion
of those crossings than any other
nationality
albanian gangs have used social media to
promote channel crossings for what they
describe as a cut price rate
we showed this video to the man in
charge of albania's border force
if we are looking for the for the
tick-tock video
it's just like for them a market and
they need to attract as many people as
they can to make to make more money
he says there is close coordination with
british authorities including flights to
bring albanian offenders home from the
uk
the uk is
one of the attractive country and there
are a lot of reasons that say why it's
attractive uh
for for the moment and one of the thing
is that also the smugglers are trying to
to find the weakest point on the system
albania is a poor country the average
wage is under 400 pounds a month but
some things unite it with britain
performing a free concert to a huge
audience in tirana the singer rita ora
born in kosovo to albanian parents she
grew up as a refugee in london but in
this country she is a hero
so what do her fans think of britain i
think it has better opportunities
because we are like a smaller country
and stuff but uh i don't know it seems
great to go there and live so there's
strong affection for the uk but with no
water flea and notorious connections to
organized crime gaining refugee status
in britain will be a struggle for many
albanians but that is the dream that
continues to be sold by people smugglers
adam parsons sky news albania